all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with invincible yes
we are the story which is amazing
so in the last video i left you guys off
on yet another cliffhanger where
basically alan the alien was confronted
by thrag right we call him freddie
mercury here on comics actually you know
what you guys call him freddie mercury
here on comics explained and i am now
obliged to call him that i mean he looks
like freddie mercury right i mean come
on you know but anyway so the idea here
is that alan the alien and oliver were
going to basically discharge the scourge
virus on earth which is guaranteed to
kill the viltrumites but may also
destroy humanity and where nolan omniman
was against it and basically had the tar
beat out of him by allen alien for his
insubordination and his willingness to
stand in the way that mark was very much
willing to do the same thing the
difference here is that thrag had
basically shown up right at the last
minute when a fight was breaking out
between alan the alien and mark and
basically is now confronting alan about
what's going on so the funny thing about
this and really the way this picks up
here is that thrag makes this just kind
of really convincing argument very very
fast one of the things he asked him he's
like so so here's my question right he's
like you show up here with the scourge
virus in hand one we knew you were here
right like our ability to monitor this
entire solar system it exists like do
you really believe that we would take up
residence on this world without the
ability to know what threats may face us
from beyond this world which makes sense
tell me why shouldn't i kill you right
now and the response of alan the alien
is he basically pulls out a weapon which
has a single dose of the scourge virus
and at that point it basically tells
freddie mercury because i can shoot you
with this thing and it'll essentially
kill you now here's one of the funny
things about this freddie mercury is
very very intelligent when it comes to
how it is that he deals with anybody
else out there especially when it comes
to him being a leader and one of the
things that he says is he's like i have
i'm fighting back every urge i possibly
can to rip you limb from limb right now
which he could despite how powerful
ellen the alien is freddie mercury could
just rip him apart with the the greatest
of each remember he's the leader of the
vulture mites he's the best of the best
and so the thing about this is he says
if that were to happen let's say for
example that i were to kill you or you
were to shoot me or something along
those lines he basically says we would
end up right back where we are and so
much like he did with mark and omniman
he simply says i would like to propose a
truce and that's when he really comes up
with this genius idea so the stance he
takes is that yes allen the alien could
shoot him with that dose of the scourge
virus and it could very well kill him
right now the scourge virus doesn't kill
instantaneously though it's not as
though he would shoot him and he would
immediately die the scourge virus takes
time to run through the bloodstream and
it actually spreads by contact and so
because of this if freddie mercury is
shot with this scourge virus then it
would basically lead to him killing
allen alien right off the bat and then
of course he wouldn't travel back to
earth because he wouldn't want to kill
off the rest of his race so he would
likely leave and travel out into space
he probably wouldn't make it back to the
headquarters of telesco the coalition of
worlds he wouldn't make it back there in
time so he would likely just slink off
to some part of space and then just
succumb to the virus and die but because
of the fact that alan the alien would be
dead and because there's no way allen is
foolish enough to bring a singular dose
of the scourge virus here that it's all
being held off somewhere that ultimately
he would be succeeded as the coalition
leader his successor would come to earth
and the whole thing would happen all
over again and so what he says here is
you are under a tremendous amount of
pressure as the leader of the coalition
of worlds to do something about us as
the vulture might race here's the
problem there's nothing you can do i
mean technically he could but freddie
mercury actually appeals to the
empathetic side of alan alien and simply
saying you've been thrust into this role
and you were put in this position
without really understanding what this
role entails and i would like to believe
that over the various conflicts that
we've had i've learned to understand you
well enough to know this is not
something you actually want to do you're
doing this because the coalition is
telling you to but it's not really
something that you actually want to do
and he's like if you look inside
yourself you'll come to the conclusion
it's true you don't want to release the
scourge virus on here and potentially
eradicate the whole of humanity but
you're being told the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and to a
degree that's an accurate statement but
remember the entire concern of the
coalition of worlds and everybody else
out there in the universe is that the
viltrumites will reside on earth long
enough to basically repopulate their
race to a substantial number and then go
back on the attack in the universe
itself right go back to their ways of
trying to conquer worlds and rebuild
their empire the truth that freddie
mercury is offering here is that they
will stay on this world they won't go
back to their ways of trying to conquer
the universe or anything along those
lines now allen is not immediately on
board with that his stance is i mean we
can't necessarily trust you but the
response of of freddie mercury is but
like you're back into a corner so you
really have no choice here there's
really nothing you can do every time you
come back here we'll kill one of your
coalition members and we'll do it
preemptively right like you're gonna
have to be in proximity of this world to
fire off the scourge virus and our
technology is sufficiently advanced
enough that we can detect your coming
arrival so we'll fly out there we'll
obliterate your ship we'll kill
everybody on board and then we'll come
back and that'll just be the way things
are from now until however long we'll
destroy the invading enemy force and
that's basically it and so where oliver
is actually tired of the whole
conversation and initially goes to
attack the response of alan is no thrag
is right right thrag is accurate here
like it really is in our best interest
to let the earth be and at that point
the worst possible thing happens the
guardians of the globe show up right
these guys these meddling kids so these
guys show up and of course they're
sitting here by like cecil right because
that old man can't mind his own damn
business and so because of that they
start kind of asking questions right
like what's going on here like who is
this guy different things along those
lines and mark tries to immediately
neutralize it right remember mark is a
fugitive as far as the superhero
community and law enforcement go so the
fact that he's here dealing with what
appears to be a threat off world seems
to indicate to all of these guys that
he's working against humanity or at
least setting the stage for some kind of
an attack against the human race of
course it's opposite of that but because
of the fact that the guardians of the
globe don't really know exactly what's
going on their stance is okay everybody
here right so like alan and thrag and
and oliver and mark like you guys are
all basically gonna be detained back at
the pentagon until we can get all this
sorted out but the response of mark is
that's not going to happen there's no
way it's going to happen and then at
that point it leads into an attack now
freddie mercury is just kind of watching
all this unfold right and so is alan the
alien the freddie mercury's response is
particularly interesting he's just kind
of like i mean this is interesting right
like monster girl steps in and tries to
attack him and he just kind of casually
dodges the attack right because she's
just painfully out of her league here
but the overall gist here is that
freddie mercury seems to be largely
dismissive right he's just i mean and it
makes sense it's it's all so far beneath
him right like no one on the guardians
of the globe is a credible threat to
freddie mercury right so which is kind
of like i mean you guys really going to
like attack the guy who just saved your
world like this is kind of ridiculous
but in the middle of it all ultimately
oliver gets fed up he basically grabs
the scourge gun and then flies into
earth's atmosphere with the intention of
just like basically firing the scourge
virus into the atmosphere of earth and
eradicating all the viltrumites possibly
even destroying humanity in the process
now mark ultimately catches up to him
and so a fight actually breaks out
between mark and his brother which is
cool it's not a great big huge conflict
right it's not like a like a fight to
the death or anything like that nowhere
near as significant as the fight between
mark and omniman but it is still a cool
battle mark of course ends up getting
his hands on the on the gun itself and
then as things progress uh basically
allen alien stops the entire fight in
space and it's like the entirety of your
world's at risk i have to go so he
basically races off and then at that
point the guardians of the globe were
like who are you freddie mercury like
what's your deal here right so basically
the superhero community is coming face
to face with the leader of the vulture
might for the very first time and
learning about the race's existence at
least outside of whatever they overheard
in the fight between mark and omniman
but when you get back to mark and oliver
the two of them are basically wrestling
for this gun and then ultimately oliver
fires it off by accident and shoots mark
in the face with the scourge virus right
now mark of course passes out goes
crashing back down to the ground or at
least starts to crash down to the ground
allen catches him and then mark
basically comes too and that's the crazy
thing is because alan's like okay dude
are you good can you hear me and mark's
response is yeah man i'm fine the blast
just caught me off guard but like
everything is cool the big concern mark
has is because the gun was fired in the
atmosphere what's the range right like
is it going to just spread throughout
the world like how's this whole thing
going to work and that's when alan says
no no no that was a singular shot right
like we fired it over the ocean it's not
going to be a great big huge deal it'll
seep into the water maybe if that but it
was designed to be a singular shot that
would only work in a limited range the
nature of the scourge virus is that it
relies on personal contact so you've
been infected if you go and touch a
person that person will infect more
people and then it'll spread
exponentially right that's what led to
the scourge virus infecting the entirety
of the vulture might race so incredibly
fast is one person's infected that
person touches two people those two
people touch four people four becomes 16
16 becomes 32 32 becomes 64. you see
what i mean it just starts multiplying
exponentially so like literally within a
day the entirety of the vulture might
race it's pushed to almost complete and
total extinction that's what would
happen here on earth and so the response
of alan is no like you have to be
quarantined you can't be around here
right like you can't you can't touch
anybody you need to be quarantined you
need to be kept away you're exposed to
the virus you could literally be patient
zero you could be the thing that would
kill the world but the response of mark
is no i'm fine right like i don't feel
sick like everything's cool but the
response of alan the alien kind of
hearkens back when he's like no the
virus incubates in the body it's not an
immediate reaction so you have to be
quarantined here but in the middle of
mark fighting and arguing suddenly alan
the alien begins to freak out and the
reason why is because mark is showing
all the symptoms of a person who's
succumbing to the scourge virus in
effect mark is dying with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace